fastuoso desmesurado con los saltos
me voy parece siempre aspirar a llevar a
cabo los proyectos más grandes más
lujosos y más excéntricos del mundo en
este pequeño territorio perteneciente a
los inmediatos árabes unidos y situado
un niño estratégico enclave la
desembocadura al golfo pérsico podemos
encontrar el edificio más alto del hotel
más lujoso incluso el aeropuerto
internacional más grande del mundo el
proceso de crecimiento de dubai está
siendo uno de los más veloces de toda la
historia del ser humano y en poco más de
20 años ha pasado de ser un remoto
enclave en el desierto a convertirse en
una de las grandes capitales del mundo
en este periodo ha logrado multiplicar
por 4 su población por 9 número
visitantes y por 8 el tamaño de su
economía pero cómo ha sido todo esto
posible se debe todo el petróleo hoy en
visual política hablamos de uruguay
dubai ya la cuarta urbe con más
visitantes internacionales del mundo
superando a epicentro del turismo y el
comercio global como nueva york hong
kong o singapur
dubai es un estado dentro de los
emiratos árabes unidos- podríamos
calificar su gobierno como una teocracia
islámica que restringe buena parte de
las libertades civiles sin embargo si lo
comparamos con sus países vecinos
dubai es sin duda el lugar más
aperturista de la zona por ejemplo las
mujeres pueden ir por la calle sin velo
analí se llama engañó dubai no aspira a
ser lugar más libre de la tierra pero si
el más rico las muestras de opulencia
son tan evidentes que no es extraño ver
a la policía del emirato patrullando las
calles a bordo de ferrari solas borgini
y qué otro lugar podemos encontrar algo
así
hay quien puede pensar que todo el
proceso se debe al oro negro que dubai
no es más que un sueño de ge que es
financiado con petrodólares sin embargo
aunque la influencia del petróleo es
innegable y ha sido un gran aliado la
verdadera clave para su desarrollo ha
sido su apuesta por el libre comercio
a finales de los años 50 se descubrieron
grandes pozos de petróleo las
inmediaciones de abu dabi la capital de
emiratos la riqueza petrolífera tal que
hoy se estima que las reservas probadas
de emiratos son mayores incluso que las
de toda rusia sin embargo el caso
particular de dubai era un tanto
distinto entre dependíamos de los
recursos energéticos fósiles gas y
generación de energía y aunque agraciado
con la fortuna del oro negro sus
autoridades pronto se dieron cuenta que
sus reservas eran más bien pequeñas y
desde luego mucho más limitadas que las
de sus vecinos de hecho y frente a lo
que pudiéramos pensar el petróleo apenas
supone hoy poco más de un euro de cada
100 que genera la economía de whitey
pero que hizo en dubai para lograr
semejante desarrollo y conseguir un
nivel de vida mayor incluso que el de
sus vecinos ricos en petróleo pues
fundamentalmente apostar por atraer
multinacionales y profesionales de todo
el mundo
para ello en primer lugar dubai apostó
por una política de bajos impuestos
sobre todo si lo comparamos con los
parámetros a los que estamos
acostumbrados en europa en dubai el
impuesto sobre beneficios es
prácticamente inexistente no hay
impuesto sobre la renta y hasta ahora
tampoco había iba y si es verdad
próximamente se va introducir un
impuesto equivalente a lo que en españa
entendemos cómo iba pero el tipo que se
fija estará en torno al 4% que lejos del
21 verdad que nos afecta a nosotros
y por supuesto en dubai como podéis
imaginar tampoco el impuesto sobre los
hidrocarburos la gasolina está libre de
fiscalidad
queremos que la próxima generación sea
capaz de celebrar el último barril de
petróleo no vamos a depender del mundo
en segundo lugar
dubai recorrió un instrumento conocido
como zonas francas si bien en este caso
un tanto diferentes a las que podemos
encontrar en otros lugares en dubai
estos espacios además de tener
beneficios fiscales también cuentan con
sus propias leyes enfocadas siempre a
promover la actividad empresarial
algo que es trascendental en esta parte
del mundo gracias a tener normas
específicas los empresarios pueden
escapar a la rigidez de los sistemas
legales inspirados en la sharía la
aplicación por supuesto en el resto de
eliminar un buen ejemplo de este modelo
ser conocido como centro financiero
internacional de dubai que es casi un
estado dentro de otro estado el centro
financiero cuenta con su propio sistema
judicial de inspiración anglosajona y
que está presidido por un juez británico
su propia lengua oficial que no es el
árabe sino el inglés e incluso ha
sustituido el dirham emiratí por el
dólar americano como moneda vinculante
de esta forma una entidad financiera
puede hacer negocios como si estuviese
manhattan pero beneficiándose de las
ventajas fiscales de dubai
así no resulta extraño que esta zona
haya sido capaz de atraer a la mayoría
de los 25 bancos más grandes del mundo
junto a las zonas francas y la política
de impuestos bajos y el inec también
apostó por la libertad migratoria y hoy
el 96% de sus habitantes ha nacido en el
extranjero y también apostó por promover
la inversión extranjera de hecho en el
año 2002 las autoridades del emirato
presentaron un decreto por el cual
cualquier extranjero podía realizar
inversiones inmobiliarias algo realmente
infrecuente los pensadores comenzó
entonces una época dorada en la que se
sucedieron los grandes proyectos
fastuosos cientos de rascacielos
imponentes centros comerciales grandes
resorts e incluso islas artificiales de
hecho en este periodo
dubai ha tenido un desarrollo
inmobiliaria sólo comparable al de
shanghai ciudad con 13 veces más
habitantes y donde antes había un
rascacielos hoy hay más de 700
el último gran proyecto sobre la mesa es
the moon of the world un gigantesco
espacio de más de 4.5 millones de metros
cuadrados llamado a convertirse en el
mayor centro comercial del mundo y que
albergará incluso su propio distrito
cultural con decenas de teatros y cines
100 hoteles y el mayor parque temático
cubierto del mundo el proyecto ha sido
presentado como la primera ciudad con
temperatura controlada del planeta todas
estas políticas han hecho de dubai un
lugar donde es fácil hacer negocios y lo
han convertido no sólo en una potencia
comercial turística y financiera sino
también en una potencia logística e
industrial
hoy dubai es la tercera mayor fuerza
exportadora de todo el mundo en su
producción industrial supera los 50 mil
millones de dólares cada año mientras
sus vecinos observan inquietos como el
precio del petróleo se desploma y hay
analistas internacionales que cuestionan
incluso la solvencia de muchos de estos
países como es el caso arabia saudita el
gobierno de dubai se muestra confiado e
incluso su presupuesto para 2016 lo ha
incrementado en un 12 por ciento
edwin más tenemos que aprovecharnos de
la crisis presenta oportunidades para
nosotros
es verdad desde una óptica estrictamente
política existen muchos elementos
reprobables en materia religiosa social
y de derechos humanos desde luego no
queremos obviar esta realidad pero no
podemos dejar de prestar atención a los
logros que has cosechado este lugar y
precisamente esto es lo que genera la
pregunta esencial es posible
compatibilizar ausencia de derechos
civiles con crecimiento sostenible la
historia y la evidencia empírica parecen
demostrar que no pero en un mundo cada
vez más presionado por impuestos muy
altos y regulaciones de todo tipo
autoridades parecen empeñadas en
demostrar que esta vez si es posible de
momento su apuesta por el libre comercio
y la inversión y sus políticas
encaminadas a reforzar la seguridad
jurídica la facilidad para hacer
negocios y mantener los impuestos bajos
han tenido un éxito superlativo si algo
nos muestra dubai es que el desarrollo
se fundamenta en la actividad económica
y las relaciones comerciales y no en el
proteccionismo y las políticas de
subvenciones muchos gobernantes deberían
prestar atención a los éxitos de este
oasis en el desierto